question 1 I let this to last because
it's a bit sneaky because you're so in
this mode of for goodness sake the
exercise is called circular motion of
course it's circular motion right except
if you scrutinize question one with me
it says OA is a fixed horizontal
interval of length one meter particle P
moves upwards from a with that velocity
in a direction perpendicular to OA aop
we're just going to call it theta find
the angular velocity so tell me where
they said the words circulators answer
they did it in fact if we start to draw
this thing go right whoops from color
obey is horizontal it's what made of
long okay and then they say P is moving
from a here what direction is admitting
you upwards in a direction perpendicular
here okay no circles involved what so
really this question is actually about
can you understand just like I Jamie
yeah right the difference a linear
velocity and angular velocity convert
between those in the necessary way ok so
I tried to find this is what is its this
is P here we call that fear right so in
this context amiga is still de theatre
on dt it's just the d theta/dt isn't
going to follow the nicely circular
rules for us because it's growing but
it's going up this unusual right right
um in a circle constantly your velocity
means constant angular velocity yes but
look this guy is moving up and up and up
you can imagine at this point in time at
the beginning this angles can grow
really fast right at the beginning and
then is your further and further away
right it's just going to sort of slow
right so the theta DT Omega is going to
be a very little depend I think that
they said they set at time T seconds
which is kind of a clue to you to say
this is in terms of time T seconds okay
so we've got a bit of a diagram here a
bit of a diagram um I've got my distance
there yep very good now in order to get
to feed off right do theater on dt I
need to talk about this other quantity
that's changing right it V equals 2
meters per second so i'm going to say
i'm going to call that rather X so this
guy up here is DX 92 okay obviously you
could choose anything you like but but I
think there's only one variable don't
move in a straight line let's go guys
okay so i know that DX on dt is equal to
2 so from that i can get an expression
for what x is right how do i get from
here to that what is this evil
yeah very good so I'm going to do with
definite integrals so if i integrate the
left hand side all right it's just DX so
you're going to get X I'm going to go
from naught to X so i'm looking for like
where do I start okay where am I add
that initial spot you know when am I a
on the right hand side I'm going to have
an integral it's to dt now I just figure
out what are the variables or rather one
of the boundaries that match these guys
right so at some time team i'll be at
some position X right so just 18 x what
time am I at a and the answer is 0 all
ok so this is just trying to get away
from work out the closet as a secondary
step this of course is just going to be
a next 8 and 10 on the right hand side
well I get ya there's my primitive and
now i can evaluate my own so x is just
going to be 2t that's niacin which of
course it is it time zero you start at
zero and every second that passes you're
a double event whatever time is to get
distance okay so there's my expression
now I think this is all the pieces that
you need remember i'm trying to get to
dieter on dt I know what DX I mid tier X
are so what's going to link me to get to
do theatre on d team and we're going to
do it I'm in a right angled triangle I'm
in a right angle triangle but I'm trying
to relate an angle to a side not sides
two other sides right so therefore I'm
going to have to go for trig ok so in
this triangle writing was here so that's
the opposite side and here's the
adjacent sorry this is the yeah he's the
adjacent side right so tan is going to
give me the connection between X and
theta so i'm going to say tan theta is
equal to
x over 1 which is which is 2t like so so
now how do i get to DVD on duty from
there okay so i can take 10 inverse of
both sides if I like all right or I
could yes I've got some talk on a whole
bunch of choices here right so for
example I could actually differentiate
both sides with respect to T for
instance if I do that I'm gonna have
this to overhear what I can do with this
I doing this
this is kind of like a piss it right
remember to try to get to defeat on the
t or d TMT feet are there the same thing
right just look at this for a second we
can pull a trick on this just like we've
done many times before to differentiate
something when the variable we've chosen
is wrong right this is with respect to
theta so we're going to differentiate
this with a better judgment to be done
right so if I say okay let's change that
to DP don dianda Peter right what am I
gonna have to multiply by to make sure
that this is actually all equivalent
right is this all equivalent okay so
therefore you can see implicit
differentiation does this this is what I
actually want so I'm going to get excuse
me Oh makeup that's the identity is to
on okay can someone tell me what this is
this is just sack squared theta okay but
I kind of don't want to thats that's
useless to me right so what am I going
to substitute here
do one easily make a substitution that
complicated yeah I just need to get this
back in terms of tans right pipe the
ground and is going on a media this is 2
on 1 plus x squared except I know what
10 is 2 T so this is 2 on 1 plus 14
squared are you happy with that how did
it you could differentiate this in as
many ways as you like you could take 10
in but what would happen if I took 10
inverse of both sides you would get
theta on the right hand side you would
get tan inverse of X on the right hand
side by the way why can't I take 10 mr.
both sides because that goes with me
very good I've got an acute angle so
everything is fine so I'm not going to
say that watch out I just saying zero is
inclusive you go all fine now what do i
do from here X like that what else can I
do what's the dish
yeah so far so good I want this in terms
of tea not that in terms of tea right
what I'm going to do chain rule chain
rule so if i go here to convert this
into d theta/dt a better x that's a
relief because I knew exactly what DX on
dt is if i multiplied the left-hand side
a better multiply the right hand side
like so I'm sorry that's tentative d
okay what do I do next XD so these guys
cancel right so here's my Omega that I
wanted okay over here on the right-hand
side that's just too I'll look isn't
that suspicious right and I already know
x is equal to 2t this is just like what
I happened before okay and I would view
those as somewhat cinema and difficulty
I wouldn't say what is clearly better
than the other you've got to go through
much the same steps just which angle do
you refer to get it angle so I didn't
know much